البقاء بعيدًا عن الشمس، وشرب الماء، وارتداء واقي
الشمس، فنحن جميعًا نعرف القواعد الأساسية
للتعامل مع الطقس الحار، ومع
اتباع هذه القواعد سيحافظ على
سلامة الكثير منا. وقد أظهرت الدراسات أن
الحرارة هي في الواقع أكثر
الكوارث الطبيعية فتكًا خاصة بالنسبة لأولئك الذين  هم
أكثر عرضة للخطر عندما تصبح موجات الحرارة أكثر سخونة
وأطول وأكثر تواترا بسبب
أزمة المناخ، من المهم أن
نفهم ما يحدث بالضبط
لأجسامنا عندما ترتفع درجات الحرارة، أو
العرق أو غيابه، يمكن أن يكون هذا
علامة على مشكلة متعلقة بالحرارة.
أريكم شيئًا هنا
عندما تشعر بالحرارة، هناك منطقة صغيرة
في دماغك تسمى منطقة ما
تحت المهاد هنا والتي ترسل رسالة إلى
الغدد العرقية لبدء
عملية التبريد التي تفتح المسام
وتطلق الرطوبة ولكن هذا وحده لا
يكفي  يبردك بعض
العرق ثم يحتاج إلى التبخر من
جلدك ليطلق الحرارة من جسمك إلى
الهواء،
تصبح هذه العملية أقل فعالية على
الرغم من ارتفاع الرطوبة، فكر في
هذا الشعور الذي تشعر به عند الخروج من
الحمام الساخن، وعادةً ما تشعر بالبرودة مثل
يتبخر الماء من جلدك
إلا إذا كنت في غرفة حارة أو رطبة وفي
هذه الحالة لن يحدث ذلك، تلعب الرطوبة أيضًا
دورًا في سبب اختلاف درجة الحرارة
اعتمادًا على مكان
وجودك في العالم لفهم هذه
الأنواع من الحرارة  ظروف الإجهاد
يستخدم العلماء مقياسًا
يجمع بين درجة حرارة الهواء والرطوبة
ويطلقون عليه درجة حرارة البصيلة الرطبة.
عندما تقترب درجة حرارة البصيلة الرطبة من درجة
حرارة جسمك،
يصعب عليك التعرق، لذلك ستبدأ في
فقدان القدرة على التبريد حيث
يتبخر العرق.  ببطء أكثر
الآن، إذا فقدت الكثير من الماء أو الملح
من خلال التعرق الزائد، فقد
يؤدي ذلك في الواقع إلى الإرهاق الحراري. ابحث
عن هذه الأعراض،
وحاول أيضًا تبريد جسمك
بالانتقال إلى مكان بارد إن أمكن أو
أخذ حمام بارد إذا تفاقمت الأعراض
مثل  إذا بدأت في القيء أو
تطور الارتباك، يجب عليك طلب
العناية الطبية.
غالبًا ما يتم الخلط بين الإنهاك الحراري وضربة الشمس، ولكن هذه
حالة أكثر خطورة من
المحتمل أن تحدث عندما
ترتفع درجة حرارة جسمك الأساسية إلى ما فوق 104 درجة
وستحتاج إلى رعاية
طبية طارئة  رعاية قد يتعرق الشخص بغزارة
كما تتوقع أو بدلاً من ذلك
قد يكون لديه بشرة جافة ساخنة وقد
يشعر أيضًا بالارتباك ويكون لديه نبض قوي وسريع، وذلك
لأن الحرارة يمكن أن تؤثر أيضًا على
قلبنا الذي يحتاج إلى العمل بجهد أكبر لضخ
الدم إلى سطح الجسم.  يساعد الجلد
في عملية التبريد، وعندما تتعرق
وتفقد السوائل، فإن كمية
الدم التي تدور في جسمك والتي
تقل أيضًا لتعويض
قلبك سوف تنبض بشكل أسرع مما يزيد من
معدل ضربات القلب وضغط الدم،
وهذا هو السبب في أن الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
أمراض القلب الموجودة مسبقًا  على سبيل المثال، يجب توخي
الحذر بشكل خاص خلال أيام الصيف الحارة
ويجب على الجميع مراقبة
كمية الماء التي يتناولونها لأنه من الواضح أنه كلما زاد
العرق، كلما كان من السهل أن تصاب
بالجفاف في بعض الأحيان دون أن
تدرك ذلك، نصيحة أساسية اشرب قبل أن تشعر
بالعطش وإذا كان يجب عليك البقاء بالخارج  اشرب
السوائل حتى قبل الخروج إذا كنت
تعمل أو تمارس الرياضة
فيجب أن تعلم أنك قد تكون أكثر عرضة للخطر
لذلك ينصح بشرب
كوب واحد على الأقل من الماء كل 20 دقيقة، فمع
مرور الوقت تصبح أجسامنا
قادرة على  التأقلم من خلال
التعرض المتكرر للبيئات الحارة
وأن العديد من البالغين الأصحاء سيكونون
قادرين على تجنب بعض هذه المخاطر التي
يمكن أن يشكلها ولكن معرفة العلامات
والعلم يمكن أن يساعد في الحفاظ على أنفسنا وبعضنا البعض
آمنين